we have a Fox News Alert it is a big one
a Federal indictment against Hunter
Biden now appears imminent the
president's son could be arraigned as
early as tomorrow he could wind up going
to prison The Washington Post is now
reporting that prosecutors are now
nearing a decision on felony tax charges
and gun charges after meeting with
Hunter Biden's lawyers late last week so
make no mistake tensions are very high
at the Biden White House tonight but not
just because of the president and his
deadbeat son and his potential arrest he
is a great artist by the way
um breaking moments ago the big guy
himself has been directly implicated in
a serious crime I'm talking about the
president in fact a brand new legally
protected highly credible whistleblower
disclosure might end up being the
biggest Story of the Year listen to this
according to the bombshell disclosure
detailed by Senator Charles Grassley and
Congressman James Comer the doj and the
FBI are now in possession they believe
of evidence that will prove that Joe
Biden took foreign bribes now this
document quote that this is in the
document describes an alleged criminal
scheme involving the then Vice President
Biden and a foreign National relating to
an exchange of money for policy
decisions in other words the very
definition of a high crime also a
serious felony that if proven true could
result in impeachment possible
imprisonment of Joe Biden your president
now the allegations clearly that serious
the document also reportedly includes a
precise description of how the alleged
criminal scheme was employed as well as
its purpose but tonight we uh we don't
know if uh Federal officials ever even
bothered to investigate or authenticate
these very serious and precise claims in
any way shape manner reform now remember
the hunter Biden laptop that was in the
FBI's possession since December of 2019.
we still don't know for sure if
investigators even attempted to verify
the contents although John Solomon he
will be here in a moment he says in his
reporting that in fact the FBI did
verify that the laptop from hell was
authentic in the spring of 2020. if that
turns out to be true the next logical
question would be well then why was the
FBI meeting weekly with big tech
companies warning them being victims of
a possible foreign disinformation
campaign in the lead up to the 2020
election uh and the head of Twitter
integrity at the time A guy by the name
of Joel Roth you know telling the Aging
Missouri now Senator Eric Schmidt that
the misinformation oh it may be about
Hunter well they knew Rudy Giuliani
Trump's attorney had a copy of the
laptop of course it was going to be
leaked now meanwhile in a very defensive
public statement the Biden White House
accused Republicans of floating
Anonymous innuendo and quote when it
comes to President Biden's personal
finances anybody can take a look he has
offered an unprecedented level of
transparency uh not quite so in the
spirit of unprecedented transparency
let's say uh perhaps the White House
should call on the FBI to release the
document in question right now if the
whistleblowers allegations are just
baseless and politically motivated
attacks as the White House is claiming
and I don't think that will be a problem
but don't hold your breath house
oversight committee chair Comer has
already subpoenaed the document in
question but don't expect the oh so
transparent White House to lend a
helping hand in fact don't expect Biden
to be transparent in any way either or
honest for that matter you know we're
still looking for answers to the
following questions how much money has
the Biden family made how much were the
deals with China and Russia and Ukraine
and Kazakhstan and about a dozen a dozen
other countries and how much profit did
they make and what were the countries
expecting in return for these deals why
didn't hunter hunter or did Hunter
register as a foreign agent while
working on behalf of foreign Nationals
and the big question is what did your
President Joe Biden know and when did he
know it and did Joe Biden make any money
from any of these deals with Hunter
Biden and his foreign business partners
and if he did make any money how much
money did he make remember Hunter
complaining bitterly that pops took oh
half his income and they he had to pay
for pop home repairs and of course set
aside ten percent for the big guy we all
know is Joe Biden so why according to
Chairman Comer were 12 different members
of the Biden family reportedly now
raking in proceeds from these countries
and as chairman Comer outlined why did
the Biden uh set up all these quote
llc's that seem to be shell corporations
to distribute the money and here's the
big one why did Biden lie to every
American over and over and over again
about never once talking to a son Hunter
about his farm business deals he said he
never had never one time ever talked to
Hunter about any of these foreign deals
but yet will we have even photographic
evidence now is your president
compromised with China with Russia
Ukraine did he take foreign bribes is
this Smoking Gun evidence has it been
destroyed and is the doj even
investigating what a very Syria his
allegations or will they use the case
against Hunter to Shield the president
and block document disclosures and
mitigate any potential Fallout by
narrowing the scope of this
investigation hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else